so you're a Ray Kroc in the 1950s a
mediocre salesman with the dream of
becoming insanely Rich one day but so
far you haven't had any luck after
trying to become a Red Cross ambulance
driver a real estate agent a jazz
pianist and even a flower seller you
ended up selling milkshake blenders it's
something but you hated it who gets rich
off of selling milkshake machines nobody
but one day your luck changes just when
you least expected it you got a huge
order for your machines from a random
little restaurant in San Bernardino
California the order was way bigger than
the ones you're used to especially for
such a small restaurant what kid they
need that many milkshake machines for
something was going on here you could
smell money and opportunity in the air
and you just had to find out what was
going on here so you drove across the
country to give the mysterious
restaurant a visit yourself a restaurant
called McDonald's the place was run by
Two Brothers Maurice also known as Mac
and Richard McDonald but this wasn't any
ordinary restaurant though it was a
well-oiled machine McDonald's only had
three things on the menu hamburgers
french fries and milkshakes they didn't
offer any seats or tables inside for
their customers and everything was
served in a disposable to go bag the
business model was basically hurry up
take your food and get out and although
we're used to this today back then this
was revolutionary everything was precise
in time down to the second all based on
a cooking system that worked like a
factory line to make sure every order
went out perfectly and fast and
customers loved it they were lining up
around the block to buy a hamburger from
McDonald's it was a completely new type
of restaurant at McDonald's people
didn't have to sit down at a table and
wait for 30 minutes before they get
their food they could order and start
eating in around 60 seconds and because
the brothers built such a good system no
matter who was in the kitchen the
burgers would taste exactly the same
every single time the McDonald's
Brothers has single-handedly created
fast food and their pitch you won't get
such a delicious hamburger for as low as
15 cents in such a short time anywhere
else as you witness McDonald's in action
you had realized that you had just
stumbled upon an untapped gold mine here
was her road to riches here was the
thing that would make you a millionaire
you were gonna take the McDonald's model
and build a fast food Empire to take
over the world but first you would have
to get in bed with the McDonald's
Brothers stay dangerous subscribe for
more and this is how Ray Kroc stole
McDonald's
next time
if you want to live longer and healthier
you obviously want to cut out McDonald's
but to take it a step further leading
scientists like Dr David Sinclair have
spent their time researching how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and they found some very
promising discoveries that is why I use
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these scientific breakthroughs into
products that hold the potential to
increase longevity and one of their
products I take every day is cell being
cell being helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD plus is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels help improve your metabolism
repair damaged DNA and it wraps up
energy production in your brain immune
system and muscles but the problem is
your NAD plus levels go down as you age
and you can't take NAD plus as a
supplement because it's too big for your
cells to absorb that's why Verso cell
being contains something called nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels more than just taking one of
them on their own and that is why I take
this stuff every day but my favorite
part about Verso is that they publish
third party testing on every batch they
produce to absolutely guarantee that
you're getting what you're paying for so
head over to ver.so Jake Tran or use
coupon code Jake Trend at checkout to
get 15 off that's ver.so jtran with the
link below thanks to Verso for
sponsoring this video
McDonald's Brothers had humble
beginnings they were born into a poor
Irish immigrant family living in New
Hampshire their father Patrick used to
work as a shift manager for a shoe
factory to support the family but after
42 years of grinding it out he was laid
off and told he was too old to work
there anymore suddenly he was left with
no severance package no retirement no
plan for the future absolutely nothing
and it was in that moment of desperation
that the McDonald's Brothers knew that
they would have to take the mantle and
go out there and make some money and
they set a goat to make a million
dollars by the time they were 50 years
old so they decided to head out west and
search for their Fortune all the way to
California in California they tried
working on film sets to even operating
in movie theater but everything they try
to fail miserably and then to top it all
off the Great Depression hits and things
get much worse for the brothers the
brothers needed to find a way to make
money but no one was spending money on
movies and other non-essentials anymore
it was the Great Depression after all if
you could afford a house cart and food
you were lucky and that's when it hit
them the one thing everyone needed no
matter how poor they word food so the
brothers reused their uniforms from
their failed movie theater business and
they started a restaurant where waiters
would take orders from people's cars but
as they ran the restaurant they noticed
an interesting pattern out of everything
they had on the menu there was one thing
that people ordered more than anything
else hamburgers they were selling more
Burgers than anything else so being the
Geniuses that they were they thought why
not give people what they want and just
sell Burgers nothing else so the
brothers pivoted and after a quick
rebranding the brothers officially
opened up the very first McDonald's in
1948 and slowly but suddenly McDonald's
became a massive local success so we
decided let's let's try let's hang on a
little bit longer so we did we're on
about the end of the third month it
began to pick up a little this new type
of restaurant a fast food restaurant
attracted customers who were in a hurry
and needed something quick affordable
and tasty to eat students cab drivers
construction workers Travelers and busy
families were their best customers and
within just a few years the McDonald's
brothers were so successful that they
started expanding and opening up new
locations all across the states they
worked with an architect to design their
signature yellow arches that could be
seen from a mile away and it was looking
like McDonald's might be on its way to
becoming a household name in the
restaurant game and that's when our guy
Ray Kroc stumbled across McDonald's and
saw the opportunity of a lifetime
foreign
[Music]
knew he couldn't just walk into
McDonald's and take over the business
overnights if he wanted to know
everything about the business he would
have to do it from the inside he would
have to earn the brother's trust so he
went up to them with the best salesman
smile and told him just how impressed he
was with McDonald's he saw real
potential in the business and wanted to
be involved and the brothers were
flattered they knew their business was
doing well but here was someone who
actually wanted to invest in their dream
and since they already started
franchising McDonald's they thought the
next logical step was to work with
people like Rey people who wanted to
open other McDonald's across the country
and thanks to Rey's years of being a
Salesman it didn't take long for the
brothers to give him a 10-year Master
franchise agreement to open a franchise
McDonald's throughout the US and that's
all Rey needed to hear he practically
ran back to Illinois to start signing up
franchisees and he didn't just want to
open up a restaurant here and there he
wanted to create a giant network of
McDonald's by the following year Rey set
up the McDonald's System Incorporated a
predecessor to the McDonald's
corporation he founded another company
to handle all the Brand's real estate
deals so he he could get as many
McDonald's restaurants up and running as
possible he was on a mission to build a
kingdom of McDonald's restaurants all
across America but the brothers started
having second thoughts they were tired
they had been grinning out for decades
since they moved to California to try
and make it big they wanted to settle
down they want to get out of the
restaurant game and enjoy their riches
and peace taxes were killing us Richard
told the Wall Street Journal in 1991. we
weren't kids anymore and so Rey and the
brother started bumping heads Ray wanted
to expand at all costs Ray wanted to
shake things up and keep innovating but
the brothers just wanted to maintain
their lifestyle the tension between them
got so bad that Rey went up to them and
said look what is it going to take to
make you go away the brothers said 2.7
million dollars we want a million
dollars each and seven hundred thousand
dollars to pay our taxes that's how
practical they were and they were happy
with that so in 1961 the brothers asked
Rey for 2.7 million dollars and one
percent of McDonald's gross sales to
hand over control Ray quickly took the
deal but Ray didn't have that kind of
cash on hand so he went out on a limb
borrowed cash from a bunch of people
eventually coming up with enough money
to buy the rights to McDonald's and just
like that the McDonald's Brothers have
both achieved their dream they have
finally became millionaires but it would
turn out to be one of the worst
financial decisions ever made
[Music]
foreign
race should have been the best thing
that's ever happened to the McDonald's
Brothers they put in the years they did
the hard stuff and now they can finally
sit back and relax without doing any
work but at the last minute Ray flipped
the scripts he said he had the 2.7
million dollars ready for Lum but their
one percent stake in McDonald's would
have to be off the books Ray told the
brothers that including that one percent
in their agreement on paper would mess
up negotiations with new investors so
Ray promised that he would just do a
handshake deal with them and he would
pay them the one percent without an
official contract the McDonald's
Brothers trusted Rey they had been
partners for years so they all shook
hands on the deal but Rey was a man of
business not honor so the second
McDonald's was transferred over to Rey's
name he had already made up his mind
that he would not pay the brothers
another single penny now with the
brother's kick to the curb Rey was
finally free to shape the McDonald's
franchise into the fast food Kingdom of
his dreams and almost in an instant
McDonald's started diverging from his
roots for the brothers their number one
concern was putting out high quality
food and making sure their customers
were happy but for Rey his one and only
focus was growth growth was the only
metric that mattered and grow what he
did soon there were McDonald's in every
single state and after that in every
single City and after only three years
of taking over Rey had doubled the
number of McDonald's in America he even
opened up a location a block away from
the McDonald's brother's childhood home
to really rub his success in their faces
and soon McDonald's would go on to
Pioneer a lot of the fast food
Innovations we know and regrettably
consume today in 1967 the legendary Big
Mac was born in 1971 McDonald's German
in play places were born by 1977 the
Happy Meal was born to Fat enough
children all over America and By 1979
the legendary chicken McNuggets were
introduced As Americans started cutting
down on red meats the McDonald's
franchise was exploding Ray Kroc was
taking all the credit and he was not
giving the real Founders a single cent
of that promise one percent and all the
McDonald's Brothers could do was watch
as the burn grew bigger and bigger every
single day
foreign
took the McDonald's Brothers for a ride
he went from being a failed salesman
peddling milkshake machines to the owner
of a multi-billion dollar fast food
company but the brothers weren't so
lucky they had accomplished their goal
of becoming a millionaire but in the
process they lost out on hundreds of
millions of dollars it made their 2.7
million look like chump change and
what's worse is that they never even got
their recognition for their role in
creating McDonald's even though it was
named after bun every year the company
would throw an annual Founders Day
celebration in honor of Ray Kroc not the
McDonald's Brothers but there was
nothing they can do legally Ray Kroc was
the rightful owner of McDonald's and
mentally it tore the brothers apart they
eventually begged to know why Ray just
didn't steal the fast food business idea
instead of taking over McDonald's his
response the McDonald's name Ray said it
was such a nice simple sounding
All-American name that he could never
compete with that's why he couldn't
resist after all could you imagine a
fast food chain named Crocs the
McDonald's Brothers didn't realize just
how powerful and valuable their fast
food restaurant
but Ray Kroc didn't he saw McDonald's
for what it could be and today
McDonald's brings in 23 billion dollars
in Revenue which means that the
brother's one percent would have come
out to 230 million dollars a year but
instead all they got was a measly 27
million dollars in today's money the
lesson whenever you're doing business
get the terms done on paper today
there's still speculation if the
brothers actually did ask for that one
percent or not but regardless the
McDonald's brothers did find some Solace
when asked if they regretted selling one
of the brothers replied no I would have
wound up in some skyscraper somewhere
with four ulcers and eight tax attorneys
trying to figure out how to pay all my
income tax we had three homes and a
garage full of Cadillacs and we didn't
owe it done to anyone I have zero
regrets Yachts on the Riviera were not
my style at all their life was great
their biographer explained they were
buying new Cadillacs every year they
were working hard in their original
McDonald's restaurant but they knew if
they sold out they would be working more
than they were now and they wouldn't be
able to maintain the quality they
achieved in the restaurant they were
ambitious enough but they weren't hyper
ambitious to dominate the world but
perhaps the most tragic part of the
McDonald's story is what was once a
respectable fast food restaurant serving
real food with real fresh cooked Burgers
has devolved into the most processed
artificial Gunk you could think of that
is literally designed to make you
addicted but you want to know what other
modern day food is also insanely
disgusting oat milk now on the outside
oh no sounds like this innocent healthy
milk alternative but on the inside oat
milk is a chemical concoction full of
seed oils emulsifiers and other
artificial ingredients in fact oat milk
is so bad that one single serving of oat
milk has the same blood sugar effects as
a can of Coke and gram for gram oat milk
has the same amount of seed oils as
french fries and yet Oli was somehow
able to fool the masses into thinking
that oat milk was cool and healthy how
well we expose it all in our new
documentary on oat milk over on our
other Channel evil food supply that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen this might be my favorite
evil food supply video yet and you are
gonna love it click the card on the
screen to watch now as stop drinking oat
milk
[Music]
foreign